[Music]
I wasn't allowed to know what date was
or even time update was officially that
didn't stop some of the more decent
soldiers letting me know what day it was
one of the date was but at least for the
first few months I had no clue so what I
did was based on something I'd overheard
I made a little calendar and kept it
hidden in one part of my cell or another
and it would mark off the days one by
one as they passed and the days turn to
weeks which tented months and then tears
[Music]
as years passed time is measured in
suicide checks every three minutes
prayer call five times a day and for the
men in maximum security
the library cart once a week is good no
look look like accent boobs back also
[Music]
now none of them want to see that
English foot just the one man I was
talking about how everything is also
where's your old books yeah I'll be back
all right she's all English hopefully
next week hopefully next week on but one
phone with someone they come in he took
me oh maybe not good didn't see anything
really I said oh why if you give me one
reason
did they give you one reason I can't oh
really
will if it's equal to you is if you to
me by psychics I'll be like six years or
seven years sandwich okay so again yes
this is also English I have no idea
those all the stories that's in there is
it a classic yes it is what other one
Steve a king you want it like a big bad
clown clown clown you know makeup on the
face big big red nose big shoes clown Oh
I mean both are pretty good but mean I
would choose this but since this has
more stories you know this does it keep
you busy